خارج صالوني حلاقه متواضع في مدينه رسنج
البرازيليه يخرج العملاء ليعبر عن ورائهم
لمنتخباتهم بتصاميم اعلامهم الملونه على
رؤوسهم هذا الحلاق اختار طرقا مبتكره
للتعبير عن فنونه في التلوين باستخدام
الورق البلاستيكي والفرشه والطيلاء حتى
نال شهره واسعه في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعد فتره وجيزه من انطلاق
البطوله في قطر
يفعلون ذلك وبدالي الامر جيدا اتصل بالبعض
ونصحوني بالمجيء الى هنا وقد قمت بذلك
قبل العمل على تصميماته يقوم الفنان بقص
شعر زبائنه وتجهيزهم لحله التشجيع
الموندياليه
لاتيه الى هنا واقوم برسم عالم البطل الا
وهو منتخب البرازيل اجواء المونديال
والتوقعات رافقت تحضيرات التصاميم الفريده
ان البرازيل وفرنسا ستكون هاني طرفي
المباراه النهائيه
بان تكون تلك الرسومات بديره خيرا على
منتخب بلدهم من خلال تتويجه باللقب السادس
في النسخه الثانيه والعشرين المقامه في
قطر